bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour suivre
en direct une nouvelle série de
questions cribles thématiques consacré
cette semaine à la réforme du collège un
texte dans l'oeil un sujet et pardon
dans l'actualité
la ministre de l'éducation nationale
najat vallaud belkacem va venir est venu
et en présence des sénateurs pour
répondre à leurs différentes questions
le débat s'annonce plutôt tendue puisque
la réforme est plutôt contesté
l'intersyndicale des enseignants a
appelé à une nouvelle grève le 11 juin
prochain
et puis cette réforme c'est de très
nombreuses vagues dans un sénat à
majorité de droite et du centre elle est
contestée
sur le fond le contenu de la réforme
mais aussi sur la forme puisque je vous
le rappelle le décret d'application a
été publié au journal officiel la
semaine dernière que ça vous donne un
peu une idée de la teneur des débats
tout de suite direction l'hémicycle pour
la séance depuis bientôt un mois
s'inscrit dans la continuité de la loi
de refondation de l'école initié par
votre prédécesseur monsieur vincent
peillon
elle concerne principalement le contenu
des enseignements les outils
pédagogiques et l'organisation du temps
scolaire
même si nous nous inquiétons du court
délai entre la publication du décret et
sa mise en oeuvre à la rentrée 2016
les membres durs groupe rdse et moi même
tenant à réaffirmer notre soutien au
collège unique
cet outil met au service d'une ambition
démocratiques fortes assurées au plus
grand nombre de jeunes le maximum de
chance comme le prônait jean zay
ministre de l'éducation du front
populaire en 1936 est entré hier au
panthéon le collège unique parachevé par
la loi haby chers collègues en 1975 a
permis d'ouvrir les portes de la
connaissance à toute une classe d'âge
qui jusqu'àlors en était privée est
entré prématurément dans le monde du
travail
les dispositions de votre réforme
propose de dégager davantage de temps
trois heures en sixième une à deux
heures les autres années
pour un accompagnement personnalisé
pouvez-vous en définir le cadre plus
précisément l'instauration d'
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
insuffle un renouveau pédagogique c'est
bien mais pensez vous qu'une année
scolaire suffira pour adapter d'urgence
l'organisation de la formation continue
avant la rentrée 2016 nous tenons aussi
à vous interroger sur la place des
enseignements disciplinaires
fondamentaux au sein de cette réforme au
premier rang desquels doit figurer le
français constatant une diminution du
volume du volume horaire accordée au
français en sixième est convaincu avec
les membres du groupe rds ce que la
réussite scolaire dépend de la maîtrise
de la langue française dans orale
qu'écrite puisqu'elle rend possible
l'apprentissage des connaissances des
savoir-faire des nouveaux moyens de
communication et d'information sans
oublier la formation de l'esprit
critique
quels moyens entendez-vous déployés afin
d'en faire la pierre angulaire de la
réforme du collège en augmentant les
horaires en 6e plutôt qu'en les 10
millions je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et cas majeur à
l'aube el khattabi liste de l'éducation
nationale peuvent et la parole de la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice françoise laborde la réforme
du collège a un objectif très simple en
effet faire mieux apprendre chaque élève
pour les faire tous mieux réussir et
vous avez eu raison de le dire et nous
partageons évidemment votre ambition il
nous faut affirmer ici que la réussite
la réussite scolaire doit être offerte à
chaque enfant en particulier lorsqu'on
parle d'enfants de moins de 15 ans et
qu'un bagage commun doit être donnée à
tous ces enfants de moins de 15 ans qui
fréquente le collège que nous voulons
unique nous réaffirmons cette ambition
mais que nous ne voulons plus uniforme
c'est à dire qu'il doit mieux s'adapter
aux difficultés ou parfois aux avances
de chacun des collégiens qu'il reçoit et
c'est pour cela que la réforme a prévu
d'innover dans les pratiques
pédagogiques d'introduire davantage
d'accompagnement personnalisé
de travail en petits groupes et de créer
ces fameux enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire sur lesquelles je
reviendrai pour répondre aux trois
questions que vous me posez
l'accompagnement personnalisé
il aura vocation à la fois à expliciter
aux élèves ce qu'on attente de les
méthodes pour apprendre la façon dont on
révise ses leçons dont on prend ces
notes dont on s'organise pour réussir au
collège vous savez que il ya un vrai
changement entre l'école primaire et le
collège notamment en classe de 6ème
c'est pour ça que de l'accompagnement
personnalisé il y en aura trois heures
par semaine pour chaque collégien
il sera évidemment fondée sur les
programmes d'enseignement cet
accompagnement personnalisé il ne s'agit
pas d'apprendre autre chose aux élèves
pendant ces trois heures
d'accompagnement que ce qu'il y a dans
les programmes
il permettra à ceux qui sont en
difficulté de rattraper ce retard à ceux
qui sont en avance d'approfondir leurs
connaissances
donc il ne porte en rien préjudice à
ceux qui pourraient être les meilleurs
au contraire il les rendra excellent les
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire je les dis c'est une
façon à la fois de faire travailler des
enseignants en équipe avec du coup
renseignements plusieurs enseignants de
disciplines différentes de faire
travailler les enfants en groupe parce
que ce sera sous forme de projets
concrets pratiques qui permettent comme
le disent les anglais de faire du
learning by doing c'est-à-dire pas
simplement des apprentissages théoriques
mais la mise en pratique de ce qu'on
apprend dans les disciplines
fondamentales
non le français n'y perd rien comme
aucune d'ailleurs des disciplines en
l'occurrence le français qui aujourd'hui
bénéficient de 17h30 de la 6e à la 3e
bénéficiera toujours de différer la 6e à
la 3e
un dernier exemple si vous prenez un
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
comme celui qui s'appelle éducation
artistique et culturelle lorsque vous
allez faire jouer à des enfants d'une
classe une pièce de théâtre c'est
évidemment pour renforcer aussi
l'acquisition du français que vous le
ferez voilà en quoi ce sera utile aux
fondamentaux madame laborde brièvement
je serai très brève monsieur le
président parce qu'il y aurait plein
question mais comme je suis la première
je sais que d'autres en poseront juste
une dernière requête pratiques que vous
vous noterez pour pouvoir nous répondre
ultérieurement pouvez vous nous indiquer
quelle incidence aura votre réforme sur
le brevet des collèges
merci la parole et notre collègue aline
archimbaud pour le groupe écologiste
avait la parole mes chers collègues
monsieur le président madame la ministre
la réforme des collèges applique les
choix du parlement qui se sont exprimés
dans la loi refondations de l'école face
au constat inacceptable d'une école qui
aggrave les inégalités et aux choix
coupable d'avoir supprimé la formation
des enseignants le collège va désormais
davantage concilier personnel mieux
préparés exigences pour tous et
attention à chacun dans les territoires
où la crise sociale frappe
particulièrement durement des équipes
travaillent déjà depuis des années avec
des résultats remarquables les
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire vont accroître leur
coopération à condition que les équipes
bénéficie pour cela de temps et de
formation cependant la russie de tous a
besoin de mixité la population scolaire
d'où ma première question madame la
ministre
comment la réforme du collège sera elle
accompagnée par une politique
volontariste en matière de mixité
sociale des élèves
par ailleurs cela ne peut se faire sans
les enseignants toujours dans cet esprit
de reconstruction d'une école plus juste
je souhaite que la plus grande vigilance
soit apportée aux remplacements
effectifs des enseignants absents des
créations de postes sont annoncées par
exemple en seine-saint-denis où ils
seraient au nombre de cinq cents pour
les trois ans qui viennent c'est un
effort mais il est insuffisant il en
faudrait trois fois plus pour que la
permanence de l'encadrement de la
continuité des cours soit assurée la
situation aujourd'hui sur certains
territoires n'est pas acceptable quelle
décision comptez vous prendre à ce sujet
enfin pour que l'école soit un lieu
d'épanouissement pour tous les élèves
il nous sommes qu'il faut qu'elle soit
un lieu bienveillant madame la ministre
au-delà de cette réforme ne pensez-vous
pas nécessaire de transformer en
profondeur les méthodes pédagogiques
notre pays d'encourager l'innovation
davantage afin d'assurer la réussite de
tous les enfants et d'encourager aussi
comme le font des pays comme la finlande
depuis des années la coopération et non
la concurrence entre les élèves
valoriser toutes les formes
d'intelligence et non pas seulement un
modèle unique qui en lestant de côté je
vous remercie
merci
pour vous répondre à parole local d'abb
la ministre merci madame la sénatrice
archimbaud pour cette question qui me
permet en effet de revenir sur ce sujet
de la mixité sociale
la mixité sociale nous la développons
oula favoriseront lorsque nous aurons et
c'est toute l'ambition de la réforme du
collège réussi à offrir dans chaque
collège de france
un niveau d'exigence un niveau de
qualité d'enseignement qui soit le même
partout et qui veillent pour chaque
enfant quelle que soit sa situation de
départ quel que soit l'état dans lequel
sept enfants arrivent en classe de 6ème
qu'il est acquis les fondamentaux qui
était attendu de lui ou pas à le faire
progresser
je crois que ce que craignent
aujourd'hui beaucoup de parents qui
refusent de mettre leurs enfants dans
tel ou tel établissement de secteur
c'est le fait que les difficultés de
quelques autres élèves au sein de ces
établissements ne soient tellement pas
bien traités qu'ils ont peur que leurs
enfants soient tirés vers le bas c'est
ça la difficulté du collège actuel et
c'est ce contre quoi nous luttons
lorsque nous disons que partout nous
voulons avoir une exigence des
programmes qui renforce l'acquisition
des fondamentaux
une évaluation qui va évoluer en effet
j'en profite pour répondre sur la
question du brevet car tout est lié
et oui le nouveau brevet en 2016
veillera à venir évalué cette capacité
non seulement à l'écrit mais aussi à
l'oral cette capacité à travailler en
groupe ces nouvelles compétences que
l'on développe dans le nouveau collège
mais pour en revenir à votre question la
première façon de favoriser la mixité
sociale c'est de veiller à ce que chaque
établissement offre le meilleur c'est ce
que nous faisons notamment en innovant
sur les pratiques pédagogiques la
deuxième façon de garantir la mixité
sociale c'est de retravailler c'est ce
que nous faisons avec des conseils
généraux des conseils départementaux
pardon pour revoir la sectorisation
avoir des secteurs plus large dans
lesquels il y ait plusieurs collèges
pour avoir davantage de pouvoir d'agir
en terme d'affectation des élèves et
veiller à ce que tout en restant dans le
secteur de son domicile
eh bien les élèves puissent être
répartie de façon plus équilibrée c'est
un travail qui ne peut pas se faire
du haut vers le bas en imposant à tout
le monde a même modèle qui doit être
très pragmatique et c'est pourquoi je
vraiment je voudrais souligner la
qualité du travail que nous effectuons
avec des conseils départementaux de
gauche comme de droite qui ont accepté
de se saisir oslo georget et puis enfin
je terminerai par la situation du
département de la seine-saint-denis
puisque vous l'avez évoqué oui
évidemment la création des postes
et puis notre capacité à avoir des
candidats sur ces postes importe on a
déjà créé 330 postes en seine saint
denis vous savez qu'on va encore ancré
500 ont conclu leur gré c'est un travail
qui est à poursuivre évidemment ma
démarche mot brièvement s'il vous plaît
merci madame la ministre
j'entends ce que vous dites notamment
sur les efforts qui sont qui seront
faits pour revoir les questions de
sectorisation je pense qu'il ya en effet
là un travail un peu faim à faire
évidemment évidemment coopération avec
la police locale
concernant ma troisième question sur sur
l'innovation
l'innovation est le fait aussi de
d'avoir sans doute de d'introduire sans
doute ou de renforcer de nouvelles
méthodes pédagogiques alors j'ai bien
compris que ma question était se situer
au delà de la réforme des collèges mais
je crois que c'est une question
importante notamment que les que les
pratiques les valeurs de coopération
entre les élèves soient beaucoup plus
encouragé qu'elles ne sont aujourd'hui
je crois aussi certains pays le font que
ce serait une façon de permettre à
certains élèves de s'épanouir davantage
de même que je crois que certaines
formes d'intelligence sont encore
aujourd'hui peu valorisées pour ne pas
dire plus j'ai pas le temps développé
mais pourra peut-être le faire une autre
fois je vous remercie bien la parole est
maintenant aux madame brigitte gonthier
maurin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen je rappelle chacun à
tenir bien les deux minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de notre question d'actualité
la semaine dernière vous avez affirmé
poursuivre l'objectif que les élèves
assimilent mieux les différentes
matières qu'ils ne sortent pas sans les
avoir comprise raisons motivant son re
re découpage entre enseignements
disciplinaires obligatoire et
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
vous indiquez que les horaires des
enseignements disciplinaires ne baisse
pas pourtant on passe bien 200 8h30
d'enseignements communs à 104 heures sur
tout le collège et encore je
comptabilise pas les horaires des
enseignements facultatifs
ce choix ne peut répondre à la
nécessaire élévation du niveau des
connaissances indispensables regard de
l'évolution des savoirs car comment
imaginer bâtir des hauts pays avec un
socle disciplinaire affaibli vous
présenter ces deux pays comme une clé de
la réussite de tous mais comment ne pas
voir que leur contenu sera variable d'un
établissement à l'autre au détriment de
discipline aussi fondamental que les
sciences la technologie ou les
enseignements artistiques qui enseignera
quoi
n'est ce pas mettre le doigt dans le
développement de la bivalence voire de
la trivalle ans les 4000 postes
annoncées pour accompagner cette réforme
en découdre est il autre élément
indispensable à 100 de votre réforme
la formation continue des enseignants
elle est en déshérence nous ne sommes
pas les seuls à nous en inquiéter j'en
veux pour preuve le référé d'avril de la
cour des comptes
ce chantier est au point mort les
enseignants français sont les plus mal
lotis de la côte catégorie a de la
fonction publique avec seulement trois
jours annuel de formation continue alors
que les pays de l' ocde en octroie 8 en
moyenne
ma question vous et que vous évoquez une
mise en route à l'automne prochain
pouvez vous me donner dès lors un
calendrier précis le contenu et les
moyens attribués en détaillant les
crédits de fonctionnement et les tp je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole à madame la ministre vous avez la
parole pour deux minutes
si monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice gonthier-maurin d'abord pour
répondre à votre question en la prenant
par la fin oui indéniablement pour que
cette réforme du collège entre en
vigueur dans les meilleures conditions
nous avons besoin de former
d'accompagner
les enseignants c'est bien ce qui est
prévu et je veux vous rassurer de ce
point de vue nous avons quinze mois
devant nous pour le faire c'est ce sur
quoi nous travaillons d'ores et déjà et
nous invitons les organisations
syndicales à le faire avec nous pour
adopter les textes d'application de
cette réforme qui préciseront notamment
le nombre de journées exact de formation
dont bénéficiera chaque enseignant qui
sera amené à mettre en oeuvre ce texte
c'est vrai qu'il y à de nouvelles
pratiques
une nouvelle culture même à adopter
parce que nous introduisons 20 %
d'autonomie pour les établissements
parce que nous innovons dans la pratique
pédagogique pour autant je veux vous
rassurer
rien de tout cela ne fragilise l'idée
d'un cadre national et d'un collège
unique bien au contraire d'abord parce
que la liberté que nous laissons aux
établissements et aux enseignants elle
est tout de même encadrée par des
horaires nationaux chaque collège
respectera exactement les mêmes horaires
par des programmes qui sont les mêmes
par une évaluation évoqué tout à l'heure
le prouver et puis que s'agissant des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire auquel vous faisiez
allusion il d'abord il ne s'agit pas de
partir dans le vague sens des
limitations puisqu'ils y a bien 8ème
nationaux qui ont été définis on pourra
revenir sur leurs détails et que ces
8èmes surtout d'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire s'appuie sur les
programmes
c'est en cela que je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il ne porte en rien préjudice
il ne laisse en rien les disciplines
fondamentales
au contraire chaque enseignante de ces
disciplines est amené à adapter une
partie de sa pratique pédagogique pour
faire faire ce que votre collègue évoqué
tout à l'heure notamment davantage de
travail en coopération aux élèves pour
sortir d'un schéma parfois un peu
théorique un peu magistral qui rend les
élèves passif là où nous voulons
et rendre créatif et acteur voilà ce que
je lui offrir merci mais voilà donc et
morat précipitent
merci madame la ministre pour ses
réponses non je veux dire nous sommes en
attente de réponses concrètes
identifiant et détaillants concrètement
les moyens qui vont être alloués à la
formation continue parce que depuis le
2010 en fait c'est moyen sont en
stagnation et de plus on sait que la
prise en charge des frais relatifs à la
formation la transporte les les
les repas ne cesse de baisser et je ne
suis pas sûr d'ailleurs je crois que la
cour des comptes le pointe que les
espèces est totalement anticipée et
intégrée
cette question en tout cas la cour des
comptes non plus ne le pense pas donc
j'attire votre attention
et puis dernier élément si j'ai le temps
en dix ans en 2009 il ya eu un rapport
de l'igpn consacré à l'enseignement
intégré des sciences et technologies qui
était et qui a évalué dans cette
expérimentation pédagogique
la conclusion c'est un succès mais la
deuxième la deuxième phase de cette
conclusion c'est que ce n'avait pas
vocation à être généralisée compte tenu
de la complexité de le faire et
notamment du besoin de volontariat des
équipes enseignantes donc voilà je
j'attire vrai monsieur je prêche
vraiment pour la tension suivi tout
particulier
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant aux dames la présidente
françoise cartron pour le groupe social
il avait la parole d'allah président
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
au travers de cette réforme du collège
vous poursuivez aujourd'hui
l'ambitieuse refondation de l'école
initié par vincent peillon 2012 cette
loi de refondation que j'ai eu l'honneur
de rapporter ici et qui a d'ailleurs été
largement débattue et largement amendé
dans certaines icicle tout d'abord
respectant nos engagements
la priorité a été accordée à l'école
primaire auparavant grande oubliée des
politiques éducatives et pourtant socle
essentiel pour la réussite des élèves
désormais le temps est venu de procéder
à la réforme du collège moment critique
de la scolarité pour un certain nombre
d'enfants fragile début avril le conseil
supérieur de l'éducation a donné un avis
positif à cette réforme du collège
et vous venez d'en publier les décrets
nécessaires à la mise en place effectif
ceux ci deux ans après le vote de la loi
dont pas de vitesse ni de précipitation
mais une ferme volonté d'avancer les
associations de parents d'élèves que
notre commission recevait hier à
l'audition soutiennent la réforme car
celle ci répond au besoin d'identifier
des enfants ils nous ont dit ce n'est
pas de plus d'heures d'enseignement dont
ils ont besoin c'est de mieux
d'enseignement mais le succès ne sera au
rendez-vous qu'à condition que les
enseignants s'approprient ces
changements et pour cela il est
nécessaire qu'ils bénéficient d'une
formation et d'un accompagnement
suffisant notamment dans la mise en
place des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire alors aujourd'hui
madame la ministre ma question est la
suivante alors que nous sommes désormais
entrés dans la deuxième étape c'est à
dire la mise en oeuvre pratique de la
réforme
quel calendrier est aujourd'hui prévue
afin de répondre aux inquiétudes
exprimées
quelles modalités de discussions avec la
communauté éducative dans les semaines
et les mois à venir
mes chers collègues le temps n'est plus
à la polémique mais au travail de
construction permettant de réussir
ensemble cette école pour tous les
enfants de france pour vous répondra par
le madame la ministre pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice cartron merci pour votre
question qui me donne l'occasion je vous
remercierai tout autant
qui me donne l'occasion de préciser une
chose il a toujours été clair pour moi
qu'il fallait distinguer une surtout pas
faire de confusion entre l'hostilité
absolue et par principe à la réforme et
les interrogations que peuvent poser un
certain nombre d' équipes enseignantes
qui sont des interrogations
professionnels et auquel il nous faut
apporter des réponses et c'est bien pour
cela que je dis que évidemment nous
souhaitons les avoir leurs organisations
représentatives
autour de la table pour construire
ensemble les textes d'application de
cette réforme
je veux répondre à certaines de ces
interrogations d'abord en rappelant que
cette réforme du collège ne se fait pas
à moyens constants
nous créons 4000 postes c'est ce qui
nous sera bien utile pour notamment
développer les petits groupes de travail
dont je disais les vertus tout à l'heure
ça se traduira concrètement pour chaque
collège par une augmentation de ce qu'on
appelle sa dotation horaire globale qui
lui permettra d'avoir davantage de marge
de manoeuvre pour renforcer ici ou là en
fonction de ce que l'établissement c'est
ça la marge d'autonomie aura décidé
comme prioritaires pour ces élèves
compte tenu de leurs besoins c'est ça la
grande nouveauté de cette réforme c'est
de permettre à l'établissement
considérant que les élèves ont du retard
particulièrement en france et ou d'untel
ou en langues vivantes et c'est de
mettre le paquet sur ces matières donc
ça c'est la première chose les moyens la
deuxième chose c'est l'accompagnement et
la formation dont concrètement c'est cet
automne et c'est pour cela que c'est
important de préparer tout ce qu'il faut
tout le cas de repos c'est cet automne
que seront formés à la fois les cadres
c'est à dire les chefs d'établissements
les inspecteurs mais aussi les
enseignants qui le seront s'agissant des
enseignants sur site ce qui signifie
concrètement que des équipes de
formateurs se déplaceront auprès d'eux
dans l'établissement plutôt que de les
sortir pour pouvoir les former ensemble
eux qui seront invités à amener à
travailler précisément ensemble de
machault conclure donc voilà les
quelques indications que je peux vous
donner
mais vous savez
madame la sénatrice aucune réforme
n'entre en vigueur on ne se met en
application dans de bonnes conditions
si nous n'accompagnons pas les
principaux acteurs les enseignants et
donc je leur roddick bien évidemment les
quinze mois qui viennent serviront à
cela mais mme cartron brièvement pour
permettre à nos collègues oui merci
madame la ministre en tout cas je pense
que la formation est nécessaire au sein
des sp mais je crois aussi qu'il faut
mieux mobiliser tous les corps
d'encadrement et en particulier les
inspecteurs des inspecteurs
départementaux qui sont plus près du
terrain et qui pourront répondre à
l'inquiétude parfois légitimes des
enseignants mais en tout cas leur dire
qu'ils ne seront pas seuls et qu'ils
seront accompagnés
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant à madame la présidente
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
union des démocrates et indépendants
oignons centre ils avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre si le rapport annexé à la loi
de refondation l'école mentionne la
nécessité de repenser le collège unique
jamais les modalités précises d'une
future réforme ont été évoqués lors des
débats au parlement ainsi des
préoccupations demeurent vives et
nombreuses parmi les élus mais aussi les
enseignants que nous avons eu l'occasion
de visionner et hier et qui nous disent
ne pas avoir été concerté donc pas mis
ces questions je voulais en pointer du
doigt une question fondamentale grandes
inconnues de la réforme qui est la
question de l'orientation
l'arrêté prévoit la suppression des
options de découverte professionnelle en
classe de 3e tandis que les classes
dites prépa-pro demeure mais sans
horaires attribués à ce jour le nouveau
parcours individuels d'information
d'orientation et de découverte du monde
économique et professionnelle qui
remplace le parcours de découverte des
métiers et de la formation ne bénéficie
lui non plus d'aucun horaires
spécifiques et devra donc être
organisées sur du temps disciplinaire
dès lors comment permettent aux élèves
de déterminer leur choix d'études et de
profession est ce là une volonté
délibérée de retarder le choix
d'orientation à la seconde est de
limiter l'orientation vers les études
professionnelles
enfin le gouvernement est déjà passé en
force sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
cette fois
on nous explique que le délai d'ici à la
rentrée 2016 permet de réfléchir au
contenu des formations des enseignants
soit mais je n'ai entendu personne se
préoccuper d'un autre aspect très
concret de la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme à savoir la rédaction et l'achat
des nouvelles des nouveaux manuels
scolaires
je ne vois pas comment les collectivités
vont pouvoir faire face à cette dépense
inédite par son ampleur alors qu'elles
subissent déjà tout le contrecoup de la
baisse des dotations de l'état hors
toutes les disciplines mes chers
collègues dans toutes les classes du
primaire et du collège sont concernés
d'où ma question comment les
collectivités ont elles été associés à
la mise en oeuvre de la réforme est un
financement spécifique par l'état madame
la ministre de cette dépense est il
prévu pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice morin desailly d'abord d'une
certaine façon on pourrait presque nous
reprocher d'avoir attendu trop
longuement avant d'adopter le ce décret
ce décret qui est tout de même la
résultante d'une loi la loi de
refondation de l'école qui a été
définitivement adoptée au parlement il y
à 22 mois 22 mois plus tard nous
adoptons ce décret alors vous dites que
il n'en a pas été question dans cette
voie de refondation je vous invite à
relire les échanges
et d'une certaine façon je regrette si à
l'époque vous n'aviez pas eu l'occasion
de poser les questions qui vous viennent
aujourd'hui je suis prête à y répondre
mais il y a eu cinq mois de débats
parlementaires cinq mois de débats
parlementaires la loi de refondation de
l'école d'ailleurs pour répondre à
certains d'entre vous qui nous demandent
pourquoi on ne se préoccuperait pas
d'abord de l'école primaire avant le
collège la loi être fondation de l'école
a précisément prévu de prendre de façon
chronologique tous les sujets qui se
posent à notre système éducatif nous
avons commencé par l'école primaire
laquelle nous avons donné la priorité
notamment avec le plus de maîtres queux
de classe où la préscolarisation des
enfants avant trois ans et maintenant
vient le temps du collège et c'est ainsi
qu'il faut procéder notamment pour
permettre à tous les enfants d'acquérir
ce fameux socle commun de connaissances
compétences et culture dont vous avez
décidé dans la loi de refondation et qui
doit se décliner avec à la fois des
programmes qu'ils soient repensées pour
mettre les fondamentaux en leur coeur
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure et
aussi un fonctionnement par cycle de
trois ans au cours de la scolarité qui
permet de mieux s'assurer du fait que
les enfants maîtrisent ces connaissances
j'en viens à votre questionnement sur la
façon dont les élèves pourront être
mieux informés en matière d'orientation
professionnelle
je peux vous dire que c'est un enjeu qui
est absolument fondamentale pour moi et
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que dans le
nouveau collège l'un des enseignements
pratiques interdisciplinaire parmi les
huit que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
s'appelle précisément monde économique
et professionnelle c'est à dire que ce
sera l'occasion pour les enfants de voir
dès la classe de 5e en l'occurrence des
sujets que jusqu'à présent il n'a abordé
qu'à la fin de la troisième comme
comment construire son orientation
découvrir des métiers découvrir
l'apprentissage dont tout le monde se
gargarise mais à un moment donné si on
veut changer notre culture à l'égard de
l'apprentissage du faut peut-être le
valoriser tôt dans la scolarité au
collège
c'est ce que nous ferons dans cet
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
qui conduira par exemple les élèves à
l'aide de leurs professeurs à construire
des mini-entreprises à permettre à
l'établissement aux modes de course le
rhône environnement économique a passé
des partenariats avec les entreprises
qui l'entourent voilà non mais je
voudrais juste répondre en détail parce
que je crois que le nouveau collège en
effet
ira à donner véritablement les clés de
leur avenir professionnel aux élèves
comme la présidente je regrette de ne
pas avoir eu de réponse sur le réalisme
de la refonte de tous les manuels
scolaires en même temps sous une petite
année les éditeurs nous disent que c'est
simplement pas réaliste sans compter la
question du coût bien sûr il faut
changer notre culture par rapport à
l'encours tissage madame la ministre
mais pourquoi est on à ce moment-là
revenu il ya un an la loi de refondation
de l'école sur les dispositifs dits
maquis favoriser l'apprentissage
voilà on prend les choses complètement à
l'envers il ya des allers retours des
atermoiements
tout ça est très préjudiciable à la
refonte en effet dû du collège le
collège unique c'est pas le collège
uniforme nous sommes extrêmement
attachés à ce que chaque enfant à partir
du socle commun trouve son parcours de
réussite puissent se voir offrir une
orientation qui correspondent à la fois
à ses aptitudes et puis à ses appétences
et en cela nous ne voyons pas en quoi
l'actuelle réforme telle qu'elle est
proposée pour a facilité les choses
enfin je terminerai en disant que jamais
dans le texte de loi proprement dit le
mot réforme des collèges n'a été écrit
prononcer nous sommes posé beaucoup de
questions à l'époque sur le statut de ce
rapport annexé au texte de loi
souvenez vous chers collègues un texte
très verbeux conclure elles ont donc
voilà donc vous comprendrez pourquoi la
suprise elle est légitime la reprise du
parlement mais aussi la communauté
éducative
la parole est à madame catherine
troendle je demande à chacun de
respecter son temps c'est aussi un
apprentissage le maîtriser le temps
madame tremblay vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues nombreux furent les
personnalités de tous bords à vous
alerter madame la ministre sur les
difficultés que soulève la réforme du
collège celle des programmes scolaires
il y à une levée de boucliers contre la
suppression du latin et du grec contre
la non ce qu'on s'inquiète
l'enseignement des lumières deviendra
facultatif en histoire tout comme le
christianisme médiéval qui deviendra une
option parmi d'autres et encore contre
la disparition des classes bilangues et
européennes qui menacera c'est certain
demain l'apprentissage de la langue
allemande
les groupes d'amitié france allemagne du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale sont
intervenus contre la suppression des
classes bilangues et européennes
j'ai moi même pris l'initiative d'une
tribune en ce sens qui a été cosigné par
plus de 50 de mes collègues sénateurs il
y a eu encore l'appel de 250
parlementaires et les pétitions
demandant la suppression de la réforme
signé par des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
malgré cela rien n'y fait vous avez
refusé de revoir votre copie et vous
avez encore fait la sourde oreille en
refusant de comprendre que la majorité
des français opposés à votre réforme la
semaine dernière ce sont les principaux
acteurs de l'éducation nationale le
personnel enseignant qui s'est
massivement mobilisée en manifestant à
son tour contre cette réforme leur voix
fait écho aux inquiétudes de
l'association des professeurs
d'histoire-géographie à celle des
professeurs de lettres mais aussi à
celles des professeurs d'arts plastiques
ou encore celle des professeurs de
langues vivantes
tous se mobilisent contre cette réforme
qui comme il le rappelle se soldera par
la perte d'heures d'enseignement
disciplinaire au moment les élèves en
ont le plus grand besoin
malgré cela vous avez décidé de passer
en force
affront suprême à tous ceux qui
expriment leur profonde inquiétude que
vos réformes votre cul sion avait publié
en catimini au lendemain d'une grève
nationale de décret ainsi que l'arrêté
portant sur la réforme au journal
officiel pour refuser tout dialogue dans
une société en crise voici ma question
est une école en perte de repères alors
qu'une réelle crise de confiance
s'installe entre des français leur école
entendez vous madame la ministre
enfin ouvrir une réelle et large
concertation sur la réforme du collège
celle des programmes scolaires je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à madame la ministre
et je lui demande de pratiquer la
contraction de texte qui est inutile
exercice voilà merci merci merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice ne m'en voudra pas mais d'une
phrase je voudrais répondre à madame
morin desailly tout de même en lui
explique enfin on lui on lui explicite
en disant mon propos je pense qu'il ya
une différence fondamentale entre à
l'âge du collège décider que tel enfant
ira dans l'apprentissage dans
l'enseignement professionnel d'office et
que tel autre aura droit à un
enseignement plus générale est donc ce
que vous proposez d'une certaine façon
est ce que nous proposons nous à savoir
ouvrir l'ensemble des élèves à
l'ensemble des matières qu'elle soit en
effet intellectuels et des disciplines
qu'elle soit intellectuel manuel que
l'on puisse y construire son orientation
professionnelle en s'ouvrant toutes les
perspectives possibles mais c'est juste
pour être clair là dessus donc j'insiste
sur ce point parce que je pense qu'il
faut bien préparer les enfants à
l'orientation professionnelle
je reviens à vous pardon madame la
sénatrice trendel bon d'abord je pense
qu'il faut à nouveau quelqu'un a demandé
de la sérénité donc sérénité à nouveau
bien distinguer réforme du collège
réforme des programmes la réforme des
programmes c'est un sujet vraiment lourd
qui n'en est qu'à ses débuts puisque
c'est une instance indépendante le
conseil supérieur des programmes
d'ailleurs dans lequel siègent des élus
de gauche et de droite qui a fait des
projets de programmes sur toutes les
matières de l'école primaire et du
collège travail considérable et je les
remercie qui nous ont été proposés qui
pour l'instant sont soumis à
consultation de 800 mille enseignants
pendant un mois
et c'est seulement au retour de ces
enseignants que nous validerons la
version définitive et je veux insister
sur le fait que moi je suis très à
l'écouté
personne ne se considèrent omniscient en
la matière vous imaginez bien le nombre
de disciplines différentes concernés et
puis le nombre de niveaux
d'apprentissage donc j'ai demandé à ce
qu'on ouvre largement la consultation au
delà des enseignants par exemple
s'agissant du programme d'histoire à de
grands historiens qui seront invités
dans un forum que nous organisons le 3
juin prochain pour apporter leur
éclairage puis nous aider
si à dire comment est ce que l'histoire
font confiance à singularité doit être
enseignée aux enfants en fonction de
leur âge
donc je crois qu'il faut en la matière
d'un sujet à enjeu vous le savez autant
que moi monsieur je presque deux mots
merci madame la ministre
mes collègues m'ont soufflé la réponse
cette réponse d'une ancienne amiénoise
un actuel amiénois me convient
parfaitement
mais au-delà de ce dénominateur commun
géographique
je voudrais quand même insisté sur
l'important l'a vraiment culture sur la
question du numérique en un mot car pour
rester parfaitement connecté il faut des
tuyaux la décision qui a été prise par
le président de la république par le
gouvernement va dans le bon sens mais je
voudrais insister sur le fait que
l'intervention publique reste
indispensable en zone rurale où les
opérateurs privés nous savons rechignent
à investir
merci monsieur le président cette étude
horloge picard de la parole et est
maintenant à monsieur jacques grosperrin
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire o dia mais la parole merci
président madame la ministre
messieurs et mesdames les sénateurs la
réforme du collège que vous avez mené
avec brutalité et dogmatisme à dresser
contre le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez les acteurs de la communauté
éducative
l'opinion publique est de nombreux
intellectuels des vrais intellectuels
comment en est on arrivé là vous partiez
cependant du bon attention si l'on en
croit vos déclarations il s'agissait
disiez vous de partir de ce qui marche
déjà sur le terrain délibéré les
capacités d'initiative
je vous donne acte de la mise en oeuvre
de la tension de la libération des
initiatives l'accroissement d'ailleurs
de l'autonomie va dans le bon sens mais
pour le reste
quel échec vous prétendez en effet
partir de ce qui marche sur le terrain
et vous commencez par supprimer les
expériences pédagogiques qui ont fait la
preuve de leur efficacité leur
attractivité
je parlais des classes bilangues et
l'enseignement des langues anciennes en
tant que matière à part entière sur les
classes bilangues vous supprimez une
proposition pédagogique qui permet
l'apprentissage de deux langues dès la
6e
et qui concerne actuellement 80 mille
élèves de 6e et qui a permis à partir de
2005 de maintenir les effectifs en
allemand en remplacement de cette
proposition qui fonctionne sur le
terrain vous proposez que tous les
élèves puissent apprendre une deuxième
langue de leur choix dès la 5e cette
modification pose trois problèmes
d'abord comme l'a relevé
monsieur ayrault il ya fort à craindre
que les élèves fassent le choix de
l'allemand contre l'espagnol ensuite nos
élèves n'auront pas le niveau suffisant
pour appréhender une deuxième langue dès
la 5e et voulu conduire et à l'échec
enfin nombreuses familles vont fuir le
collège public pour aller dans les
établissements privés que proposeront
des classes bilangues sur les langues
anciennes
vous prétendez leur offrir à tous alors
que voulait supprimer un tank
anciennement autonome qui peut croire
que les mesures de votre réformes
permettront de les sauvegarder
en réalité votre fils de l'attirer tous
les élèves vers le bas révèle une fois
de plus combien le socialisme un
problème avec l'excellence l amérique au
progrès si ma question
ne serait-il pas encore temps madame la
ministre de retirer ce texte pour
travailler en véritable concertation
avec les acteurs pour faire en sorte que
les enfants de la république réussissent
et enfin à quel moment le parlement a
dit il se prononcer sur le contenu de
cette réforme du collège qui d'après
vous fait suite à la loi de formation de
l'école minute quand même la ministre
pour répondre je suis certain que
monsieur grosperrin contractera chantons
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur grosperrin à quel moment est
ce que les parlementaires se sont
prononcés lors de l'adoption de la loi
de refondation en 2013 c'était il y à 22
mois que comporte cette réforme du
collège s'agissant des langues vivantes
puisque vous avez évoqué les langues
vivantes étrangères
elle prévoit que l'apprentissage de la
langue vivante 2 se fasse de façon plus
précoce qu'actuellement puisque
actuellement les enfants attendent la
classe de 4e pour commencer leur
deuxième langue vivante
demain il l'a commenceront dès la classe
de 5e toutes les enquêtes démontrent que
une exposition plus précoce à une langue
vivante étrangère en renforcent la
maîtrise et que cela va dans l'intérêt
évident de tous ces jeunes qui seront
amenés sans doute à rejoindre le marché
du travail dans l'est
années 2000 23 que de pratiquer de façon
aisée de langue vivante étrangère quelle
que soit d'ailleurs les métiers qui
seront les leurs les classes bilangues
que vous évoquez en réalité la logique
des classes bilangues qui consistait
donc à faire pratiquer deux langues
vivantes étrangères dès la classe de
sixième
mais pour une minorité de collégiens 15%
avait cette possibilité
la logique est non seulement préservé
mais étendue à tous les collégiens
puisque vous êtes d'accord avec moi le
bilinguisme sera désormais offert à tous
les collégiens en classe de cinquième
en revanche j insiste à nouveau sur un
point c'est que ce qu'il demeurera dans
la réforme du collège c'est la
possibilité cette fois ci garantit à
tous les élèves et pas seulement dans
les collèges qui on avait envie à tous
les élèves qui auront commencé en langue
vivante une à l'école primaire une autre
langue que l'anglais de pouvoir accéder
à l'anglais langue vivante 2 dès la
classe de sixième pourquoi est ce que
nous faisons sont conclus que nous
savons que ce qui peut arrêter les
parents dans le choix d'une langue
vivante une autre que l'anglais
c'est la crainte que leurs enfants de
l'abord de l'anglais langue
indispensable de notre monde que trop
tard en classe de quatrième et bien
aujourd'hui ce que nous leur proposons
c'est faut conclure prennent une autre
langue en élever une la lv2 anglais sera
elle accessible dès la classe de 6e
c'est une formidable façon de
diversifier le choix des langues c'est
dû en effet pur ou d'écouter pas en
place malgré un jeu grosperrin pour
conclure puisque oui très rapidement je
suis garant le kit est ici merci
président madame la ministre vous savez
très bien et les associations parents
d'élèves nous l'ont dit avant-hier que
dans la loi de repos nation l'école il
n'a pas été question du collège donc
vous avez confisquer la parole au
parlement
il faut le dire soit c'est un
rétropédalage on l'a bien compris soit
vous êtes rendu compte que il fallait
passer en force
soit vous fait de l'acceptation à ce
moment là il fallait en discuter dans le
parlement
parce que travailler sous forme de
décret ce n'est pas honorable avis en
tout cas ne me la république et deuxième
chose
ce rétropédalage on l'a très bien senti
parce qu' il fallait passer en force
vous sentiez que quelque part les
acteurs de
de la vie éducative allait agir dans ce
sens ça y est enfin je crois qu'il
aurait été plus judicieux de travailler
sur les formes d'exploitation dans
certains départements si vous voulez
véritablement cette forme de travail et
de réforme du collège merci mon cher
collègue la parole et à madame joëlle
garriaud-maylam pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole d'un chers collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les
français sont mondialement réputés pour
leur piètre maîtrise des langues
étrangères
une sous-performance bien sûr lié à
notre système d'apprentissage des
langues à l'école et au collège pas de
miracle deux ou trois heures de cours
par semaine ne suffisent pas à devenir
bilingues
la plupart des postes à responsabilités
y compris en france exige aujourd'hui un
véritable plurilinguisme les classes
bilangues européennes et internationales
permettent de l'atteindre en plus un
volume en horaires renforcés en langues
elle favorise l'enseignement en langues
étrangères de discipline non
linguistique un enseignement
pluridisciplinaire ludique ne parviendra
jamais au même objectif
ces classes sont dites élitiste mais
quel mal y at-il à permettre aux élèves
qui le peuvent de maîtriser réellement
des langues étrangères tandis que ceux
en difficultés dans l'acquisition d'un
socle fondamental en écriture on lecture
serez aidé en petits groupes
pourquoi contraindre l'ensemble des
élèves à s'initier dès la cinquième à
deux langues étrangères alors que
certains ne maîtrise pas les
fondamentaux et pourrait développer sur
ce créneau horaire des talents non
linguistique un vernis de lv2 est il
utile à la réussite professionnelle
la bi langues pour tous dès la cinquième
est un mensonge
le collège unique avait la preuve de son
échec pourquoi s'enfoncer encore dans la
même mauvaise direction généralisant le
saupoudrage en langue vivante et
ancienne plus que de ludique les élèves
ont besoin de repères
le collège doit leur donner les bases
leur future réussite
n'oublions pas la dimension diplomatique
des classes bilangues européenne leur
suppression est très mal perçue
outre-rhin
il est à craindre que par le jeu de la
réciprocité l'enseignement du français
en allemagne en pâtissent durement
l'enjeu est aussi celui de
l'attractivité internationale de votre
question ducati fans la renommée des
lycées français à l'étranger est fondée
sur celle de l'éducation à la française
remettre en cause ce modèle c'est
affaiblir nos établissements dans un
contexte de vive concurrence
internationale
je m'interroge aussi sur la mise en
oeuvre pratique de la réforme
ma question sachant que 400 millions
d'euros seraient nécessaires pour
accompagner les nouveaux programmes
pourquoi votre ministère halte il
inscrit seulement 60 millions d'euros
dans son budget triennal qui pâtira des
arbitrages budgétaires pour éviter
qu'une génération de collégiens ne soit
sacrifiée sur l'autel d'une réforme
précipitée
pourquoi ne pêchent le nez sont entrés
en vigueur ces deux ou trois ans madame
la ministre pour répondre brièvement
pour que ce soit compréhensible parce
que je vois que alesi la classe était la
discipline aujourd'hui allez-y oui
madame la sénatrice garriaud-maylam bon
d'abord pardonnez-moi mais dans votre
propos il y a quelque chose que je ne
peux pas m
contre quoi je m'élève lorsque vous
dites demain les postes à
responsabilités recueilleront une bonne
maîtrise des langues étrangères et c'est
pour cela que nous devons former une
élite à maîtriser ces langues étrangères
mais non je crois que tous les postes à
responsabilités comme pas responsabilité
recueilleront une maîtrise des langues
étrangères et c'est pour cela qu'il faut
veiller à l'offrir à tout le monde c'est
bien le sujet c'est quelle métier
prépare-t-on pour 2023
à nouveau je le dis ici je ne crois pas
à des métiers qui serait faiblement
qualifiés en 2023 je crois que ça
n'existe pas et donc sous payé
d'ailleurs je crois que ça n'existe pas
le siècle que qui est le nôtre exige que
nous ayons un niveau de qualification
élevé pour l'ensemble de la population
et c'est ce que fait cette réforme du
collège
je poursuis en vous disant que vous
semblez croire que la réforme du collège
va imposer exactement le même
fonctionnement à tous les établissements
une forme d'uniformité que vous rejetez
mais je vous comprends moi aussi je suis
contre l'uniformité et je rappelle que
s'il y avait 20
% d'autonomie dans les collèges à partir
de 2016 c'est précisément pour que eux
qui sont les mieux placés décident s'ils
consacrent davantage de temps à de
l'accompagnement personnalisé comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure où qu'ils ont
des enfants plus en difficulté ils vont
en faire plus ou alors
enseignement pratique interdisciplinaire
par exemple en langue vivante étrangère
donc si je souhaite faire davantage de
langues vivantes ils peuvent le faire
c'est à ça que sert l'autonomie je
terminerai simplement par deux mots le
premier c'est que oui la loi de
refondation de l'école et les débats qui
ont entouré a bien abordé la réforme du
collège cessé de dire le contraire
il suffit de la relire pour y voir
réaffirmation du collège unique
enseignements complémentaires autonomie
des établissements pratiquent diverses
brûlures bon et dernier mot les manuels
scolaires puisque vous nous interroger
sur ce point les manuels scolaires
évidemment seront prêts en temps utile
pour entrer en vigueur pour la réforme
en 2016 et c'était important d'avoir à
la fois une organisation du collège
échanges ainsi que ces pratiques mais
j'ai loupé les on aurait tous joué
chacun pour soi et des manuels en
cohérence aux dix secondes bonhomme
guillaume lemans d'une part vous n'avez
pas répondu sur la question du coût
madame la ministre
deuxièmement vous avez 15 % des
collégiens aujourd'hui qui sont dans des
classes bilangues il aurait fallu
augmenter ce nombre sas aurait été
important aujourd'hui que se passe-t-il
madame la ministre nous n'avons même pas
suffisamment d'enseignants en langues
nous n'avons pas les moyens de former
nous savons que nous n'avons pas été
capables de remplir les poches 100 capes
d'allemand alors de quoi smic ne me
connaît non si c'est merci imposer des
cours de l'homme par des enseignants qui
ne connaissent pas ces plantes qui n'ont
pas la capacité ce sera un échec
ma chère collègue je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de république j'invite
chacun à méditer le temps pour la
prochaine avec nous cet après-midi et
jacques grosperrin bonjour vous êtes
sénateur ump vous êtes rapporteur de la
commission denquête du au sénat sur le
service public de l'éducation et la
perte de repères républicain et vous
avez demandé à nadjaf vallaud belkacem
pourquoi l avez escamoté selon vous le
débat sur cette réforme des collèges
dont enquête dans quelle mesure elle a
escamoté le débat à votre avis ben arous
un mec ça rétropédalage parce qu'à ce
jour elle bien essayé de nous expliquer
que c'est suite à la refondation de
l'école que le décret d'application
arrive alors qu'on sait très bien que
c'est faux parce que les associations
nous ont bien dit
hier lors de cette commission denquête
que justement il n'a jamais été parlée
il n'a jamais été question du collège
dans cette loi de refondation de l'école
donc ça rétropédalage pour simplement
pour faire taire la rue pour faire taire
la communauté éducative pour faire taire
les enseignants les chefs
d'établissement il escamote le débat
bien sûr que c'était un passage en force
on le sait bien donc c'est leur
technique mais en tout cas c'est un déni
de démocratie et puis pour la
représentation nationale que nous sommes
je pense comment donner on aurait pu
dire les choses et ça c'est le fait d'un
décret d'un décret qui est inique mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
ministre est ce que vous espérez dans
les semaines à venir pour faire la faire
infléchir c'est ce que vous voulez c'est
ce que vous demandiez moi moi je lui
demandais simplement qu'elle retire ce
décret parce que je crois que c'est
important qu'elles leur retire qu'elle
permette à tous les élus à tous les
enseignants à tous les parents d'élèves
de pouvoir discuter de cette réforme là
et je suis surtout demandé s'il voulait
véritablement ce type de projet là à ce
moment là qu'elle expérimente dans
certains dit deux départements on peut
l'expérimenté la loi par contre le
permet mais pas faire cela parce que je
crois que le passage en force est
véritablement unique est insupportable
pour la représentation nationale que
nous sommes mais pourtant sur le fond y
compris dans votre groupe dans la
majorité de droite et du centre au sénat
on considère que le collège unique et
est arrivée un peu à bout de souffle que
le modèle n'est pas complètement viable
qu'est ce que vous proposez dans ce cas
là oui mais le collège unique est arrivé
à bout de souffle peut-être mais il faut
se poser la bonne question
les choses doivent se faire à l'école on
sait que 40% des élèves qui arrivent au
collège ont des difficultés pour
s'exprimer lire écrire compter
et surtout s'exprimer et qu'on a du mal
à s'exprimer c'est ce sont les gestes
qu'ils prennent la parole et les actes
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
violence
nous on voulait un autre type de
fonctionnement et a tellement il y avait
des choses qui existait était très
intéressante le l'apprentissage de la
deuxième langue en classe de 6ème et non
parce qu'ils nous proposeront en classe
de cinquième on sait que les difficultés
en français pour certains poseront des
difficultés dans les langues
il faut garder ce système d'excellence
et des classes bilangues les classes
européennes etc
c'est un système d'excellence qui
permettait de montrer c'est un marqueur
important de montrer que les élèves qui
veulent eux réussissent que les élèves
en france peuvent réussir être bien
réussir et je crois qu'à ce jour on est
dans un déni
je crois que la ministre n'a pas compris
que ça fonctionne pas comme ça que ce
n'est pas en mettant une deuxième langue
alors que la première langue ne peut
être pas bien comprise voir enseigner
mais surtout comprise parce que on
aurait pu s'interroger met une première
langue maternelle la langue française
quand même
c'est peut-être là où il aurait dû me on
aurait dû marquer la priorité vous
pensez qu'elle est mal conseil des
ministres du coup je pense que en
réalité ils passent en force ils sont
perdus ils savent plus quoi proposer la
priorité est à mettre dans le primaire
qui vient de répondre du collège c'est
important il faut la faire mais pas sous
cette forme là il lui aurait fallu une
concertation des milieux enseignants des
parents d'élèves 10 ans et non mais
aussi des syndicats on a confisqué la
parole à tout le monde d'accord je vous
remercie beaucoup et elle puis on aura
l'occasion de se revoir au moment des
conclusions de votre commission d'
enquête sur la perte de repères
républicain et le service public de
l'éducation merci beaucoup à vous voilà
donc vous l'avez vu de très nombreuses
questions pendant ces questions cribles
thématiques
beaucoup de sénateurs de la majorité de
droite et du centre ont accusé la
ministre d'avoir escamoté le débat de
passer en force c'est ce que vient de
nous dire jacques grosperrin
on accueille tout de suite françoise
laborde bonsoir ou bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la présidente de la commission d'
enquête sur le service public de
l'éducation
la perte de repères républicain est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite des réponses de la
ministre dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
alors je ne vais pas voir la langue de
bois mais je vais vous dire oui mais
simplement parce que si vous faites
référence à la présidente de la
commission denquête elle n'a pas répondu
aujourd'hui la commission denquête ce
n'était pas le sujet elle sera reçue en
audition mardi prochain pour répondre à
des questions spécifiques que nous
allons lui poser avec jacques grosperrin
sur les valeurs les valeurs
républicaines la laïcité l'école on sait
le moment pas les civils
mais aujourd'hui sénatrice alors vous
avez tous pas en tant que sénatrice j'ai
posé une question
j'ai eu une réponse je pense qu en deux
minutes
la ministre n'a pas pu répondre de façon
aussi complète que je l'aurais désirer
mais comme j'ai la chance de faire
partie de la commission culture elle rit
elle reviendra en deuxième semaine
et moi aussi je pense que la réforme du
collège
il ya des choses intéressantes le
collège unique c'est quand même quoi
qu'en disent nos amis des bords
différents du mien c'est quand même
abi habib 1975 il faut pas l'oublier
moi je me souviens j'étais en seconde ça
a été ma première manif et aujourd'hui
on se rappelle plus que c'est abi qui a
mis le collège unique
et donc pour la suite vous suivez la
ministre vous êtes d'accord pour qu'elle
tienne jusqu'au bout sa réforme avec
avec ce décret d'application qu'elle ne
revienne pas sur ce décret oui je vais
vous dire oui parce que la difficulté
des ministres d'une ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est la pression
des syndicats des parents de
l'opposition etc
et c'est pour cela que l'éducation
nationale française n'évolue pas donc
rien que pour ça je la soutiendrai même
si je suis pas d'accord à 100% surtout
ben merci beaucoup madame la sénatrice
voilà vous venez de suivre les questions
cribles thématiques consacrées cette
semaine un sujet particulièrement dans
l'actualité la réforme du collège très
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires